what's happening is this
you have to stay hard i admit uh you're
looking down
a microscope right now you're looking at
some weirdly some highly diluted milk
now if any of you know anything about
the uh the molecular structure
of milk and the fact that it's diluted
um you might be able to guess what those
weird particles are and what solution
they're sitting in if it's highly
diluted what do you think the solution
is
it's water correct what are these
molecules in there
it's the milk but particularly it's the
fat in the milk right so
yeah now i want you to look closely at
what those molecules of fat are doing
what language you use to describe what's
happening right now
they're vibrating what else would you
use that's very very specific language i
would've said
the jiggling right just like wobbling
around yeah
now here's the really weird thing you're
looking down a microscope
at a solution that's not moving at least
to our eyes it's been very still
and yet we can't help it from moving
around right and this is a very specific
kind of motion does anyone know what
kind what name we give this by the way
starts with a b named after a botanist
who discovered it looking at poland not
milk
brownie in motion please write that down
for me please brownie in motion you
didn't expect
to come here getting a physics lesson
but you're getting one because
what brown the botanist saw when he
looked at this was
he was looking at pollen like i said not
not fat but this is just a really easy
way to see what's going on
he said why why are these things that
i'm looking at under the microscope why
are they moving
like everything is completely still as
still as i can possibly make it
why are they moving about and eventually
it came upon some guy that you might
have heard of his name was
einstein he said actually i know exactly
why those are moving in that way there
is something
invisible literally invisible to our
eyes through this
scale of microscope that must be pushing
on each
of these different molecules because he
knew from physics right
things do not move unless air force acts
on them right inertia there must be
something acting
upon these small invisible particles
that we can't see
and so what einstein did was he went and
mathematically not because he had a good
enough microscope naughty browning
he mathematically proved the existence
of atoms
from looking at this motion just think
about what he did
and how that's relevant to this
we don't see any roots right they're
invisible to us but everything that we
know from
older mathematics tells us there has to
be something that apparently we can add
apparently we can multiply that gives us
something
reasonable so here's what we're going to
do
let's take this uh this equation here
right we said y equals and then we used
that to graph right
to solve this equation to find these
roots that don't exist all i need to do
is
let y equal 0 right that's how i find x
intercept so let's go ahead and do that
if i'm solving this
equals 0 i can just go through exactly
the process that i went through before
i can separate out complete the square
factorize and all the rest i should end
up
if i'm following those steps with
everything except for that y being there
should be zero
right so i should end up here
do you agree yeah now normally at this
point
and especially because we know what the
graph looks like right normally at this
point we would say
ah flip the table and walk off
no solutions but we're trying to push on
this and say but there must be something
something's pushing on these molecules
right
so let's conceive of something that can
do that in order to get at a solution
for x what would we normally do at this
point if we had like a reasonable number
like three there what we do yeah we take
the square root of both sides or we've
already done it to this side
um and we would say oh well it's going
to be plus or minus by the way
that's square root of whatever's there
okay well if we have a negative there
let's see
what happens if this is the case
some weird invisible object we've never
dealt with before okay
let's just call that a number like i
don't know what it means i don't know
where it is but if it is a number
then i get a solution for x
like this it's not in the natural
numbers
or the rational numbers or the integers
or the irrational numbers
it's somewhere else it's in a place as
many of you anticipated that we call
the complex numbers now when we say
complex and by the way hands up who's
heard this phrase before hands up i
expect most of you okay thank you
when we say complex we don't mean
complicated and messy and difficult what
we mean is
like i do you might live in a complex
and what that means is your house
doesn't stand
on its own as a separate house it's
attached to other people's houses
as well and that's what you can see here
this number that you know about
you're like i'm cool with this number
it's an integer it is attached
to this other weirdo looking number that
i don't know really what to do with
yeah okay but the fact that they they
must interact
gives us these results and i'll prove it
so the thing about this what would alpha
plus beta mean
if i contend that alpha and beta are
these guys okay
what happens when you add these here's
let's just call this one let's just call
that one alpha is that okay
and let's just call this one you might
want to drop this down with me right you
want to call this one beta
alpha beta i'm just adding them right
well
even though i don't know what the square
root of negative 3 is right
the most basic thing you can see wrong
color is that you've got a minus one
here
and you got plus one here right so what
happens when you add a number to its
negative
they cancel out so these guys are just
going to go that okay
so then what do you end up left with
yeah negative one plus negative one
that's negative two like you saw before
okay what about
this one let me take
a moment and shut up and see what you do
with it
if we call this alpha and call this beta
what emerges
when you try the working see what you
come up with
call one of us over if you get an answer
or get stuck
i noticed several of you as i was going
around right you kind of looked at this
and
after you got over your initial
revulsion of like negatives under the
square roots yeah let's let's just work
with this
um a lot of you just distributed you
expanded as far as you can go and one of
the things you will notice and we will
consistently say is that
mathematicians famously lazy always
looking for the laziest
lowest effort way to do things so when i
look at this thing i notice before i go
to expand that this is not just a random
thing to expand
right um it's in a particular format
that i recognize from like
year 8 year 9 it's a number
take away something and then the same
number
plus something what do we call that by
the way this has a name starts with a c
we call them we used it under well with
the rational numbers
this is this is difference of squares
because these two things are called
conjugates does that ring a bell
conjugates like ah
from three years ago okay now when
you've got conjugates and you multiply
them together
um what is a minus b times a plus b
what's it factorized to you
it's a squared minus b squared right
that was an
easier way than explaining the whole
thing yeah so hopefully what you got was
this
negative 1 squared that's a squared
right did i get that right
take away and then this weird looking b
thing
this squared now even though i'm still a
little confused about what on earth this
thing is
i know by definition that what a square
root is
is that if you multiply it by itself
you'll get that thing underneath the
square root you agree
square root 25 is 5 because 5 times 5
gives you
25. so therefore i'll sneak it just up
here
negative 1 all squared is 1. then you're
taking away
what negative 3. negative 3 because you
squared it you got
you got the negative back somehow that
of course gives you
the four that we had earlier does this
make sense
so these complex numbers what we say is
there is a part to them and i'll
highlight it just here there's a part to
it that we
are fairly happy with this is a real
number right it doesn't have to be um
a whole number it doesn't have to be an
integer it could be like a half or it
could even be
it could be irrational stuff there as
well but it's real and then you've got
this
other thing we call this
imaginary a real component
and an imaginary component you're
putting together and that's what gives
you
a complex number